normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government
feminism is destroying femininity it is
telling women to to adopt masculine
features masculine roles this is why men
are bad so be just like them it's it's
it's insane we we when you look at the
numbers transgender youth I think one
study said 85% were female it's mostly
women cut yeah it's mostly young girls
getting their breast cut off and wanting
to be men and what they don't realize is
it doesn't matter what they do they're
never going to be men they're still
going to be short they're never going to
like look like men they're never going
to have that power and they're never
going to have that respect and it
doesn't matter even if you put like Jace
on the name tag you know it's it's never
going to be you when when I was a kid my
mom was in a she was a corporate
attorney and um she was always she was
often talking about how she was the only
woman in the boardroom and she was like
trying to dress and be more masculine
and stuff and she and the women of her
generation I remember her friends and
you know my uh mother-in-law and
everything would talk about how they
didn't want to cook and they didn't want
to clean and they didn't want to do any
of these things and I had a stepmother
who all she wanted to do was be a mom
she wanted to be a stay-at-home mom she
wasn't able to have children of her own
and so she looked at these other women
she looked at my mom and everything and
was just horrified that they hated
everything that she wanted you know they
gave up everything that she wanted most
jeez it's the the attack on men is like
first of all let's get rid of motherhood
role models in the house the nuclear
family and then if they attack the women
it's basically they can prevent that
from ever even happening right no babies
no household you just grow up and be
miserable and then you die yes but the
the misery is coming
everyone Teri yeah single like look too
many Millennial men and women are single
and they're having families and yes uh
uh I always preface this with I am doing
my family stuff calm down everybody
because I know full well the the idea of
when Chelsea Handler said she wakes up
at 6:00 in the morning smokes she does
drugs then masturbates and goes back to
bed and I'm like that's wonderful I'm
sure she's loving it I'm not sure she's
loving it no I think it's it's it's a
dopamine hit it's triggering it's it's
dopamine but what's going to happen
what's going to happen when she's 70 in
the hospital after suffering a cerebral
hemorrhage and she's or she or some kind
of disease and she's dying and she's by
herself and the doctor says press the
button if you need us and walks out of
the room and then she's just staring at
a cold wall with with nothing to show
for it with no one around her no no
future ahead of her my grandfather was
buried today he died uh Sunday
night and it's this amazing kind of
rebuke of parts of my life I me parts of
my life he really inspired he was an
entrepreneur late in life uh very late
in life found success and and inspired
entrepreneurism in in his sons and
Grandsons in particular but other parts
of my life are very distinct from his
you know he had seven children he has 22
grandchildren great grandchildren you
know he he died basically two months shy
of becoming a great
great-grandfather
and his legacy long after the memory of
him is gone me one generation from now
two generations from now nobody will
remember his name right do you know your
great great grandfather's name and if
even if you do do you know your great
great great-grandfather's name I mean
history will forget my
grandfather but a thousand years from
now the impact of his life will still
exist through the children that he's
pushed into the future and the values
that he's pushed into those children
that get pushed into the future
generation after generation and somehow
we came of age at a time when we when
our culture ascribed not only no value
to that but negative value to it yeah
one of the what if we deprive people I I
bring this up a lot but one of those
Emanuel Brothers Rob emanuel's brother
talked about why we don't need old
people anymore old people should stop
caring for themselves and basically just
die not basically they said die you know
and I tell people all the time knowing
your grandparents is the best that was
little has inspired me in this life more
than my grandfather Yeah uh he was a a
true uh inspiration to me in so many
ways as a family man as a business guy
and and a creative and uh a lot of
people don't have that attachment to
their grandfathers or or any grandparent
and that is uh truly sad to have like
that uh to be divorced from history like
that because they can teach you so much
from the the decades that they Acquired
and all the stuff you know all the
information they got um so yeah now we
have a world where they're not having
kids to become the role models and they
don't have any connection to the past so
they'll be these very decrepit
meaningless vessels humans but I do
think more and more here we are sitting
here talking about the success daily
wire's having I mean forcing Disney to
course correct on Snow White is
hilarious and if anything that's a
tremendous Victory but let's see your
Snow White do better because you know
the these companies need to learn a real
lesson y but we're watching all these
tremendous victories we're learning now
that um there's a huge swing towards
Trump whether you're for Trump or
anybody else Biden is losing support
tremendously oh I mean SNL mocked him
for the first time so The Jig Is up what
did they do Jig Is up mocked him huh
yeah they're in trouble I didn't see it
who played
Biden do you know the names of anybody
on I don't know anybody on there anymore
as I said that I was Saturday night Sam
here's here's what I'm saying big these
here's the scary future that I see
conservatives having kids Y and Liberals
are rewarding their kids and even to
some some degrees even some of their
kids are being sterilized it's I don't
act like it's all of their kids it's a
few thousand I think and it's into tens
of thousands that are getting these
treatments but what is the future in 20
years going to be these 30 Millennials
right now what's the average Millennial
age like 36 or 37 right yeah my brothers
are that age they're nearing their 60s
they're going to be nearing their 60s in
20 years they're going to be getting
close to retirement oh who knows by them
then retirement age might be like 77 or
something especially considering the
economy now well actually I take that
back dep considering this backlash by
then retirement age might go down and
but imagine these people when they're
retired no families no savings what do
they do the inverse is that
conservatives have kids 20 years from
now there is going to be two to one
conservative to Liberal kids now people
may change their values so some of the
kids of par of conservative parents May
adopt liberal ideologies but it's also
true that the inverse could happen
especially with the push back schools I
think it's fair to say based on the fact
that liberals overwhelmingly abort
relative to conservatives and
conservatives 20 years ago were already
having more kids you are going to have
woke feminist Millennial retirees males
and females single childless begging for
handouts from a government that will not
give it because conservatives win the
voting block we talk a lot about like
the par parallel economy right but I I
really think it's going to be not
parallel realities but fractured
realities where we're going to inhabit
the real world we were talking about
before we went live about taking the
physical space back you know and they're
going to inhabit the digital space
that's where all their identities are
mostly uploaded they care more about the
digital world than they do the physical
world here here's an interesting wrinkle
on that is AI oh yeah that the digital
world is becoming more and more
artificial over time and I think that
there's going to be a reaction to that
where people want tangible physical
events and engagements yeah you
conservatives love to catastrophize
right oh AI is the end of the world is
the end of this of course it's a massive
it's another one of those massive
technological changes and the world will
change around it but there are good
things that come out of these advances
and one of the good things I suspect out
of the out of this new sort of
artificial digital age will be a return
to actual human connection I only when I
sit in a room with you and look you in
the eye and talk to you do I know that
you're a real person it's like looking
at people go back and getting into vinyl
again after being yeah I mean kid kids
still go ride bikes totally you know my
my fear is that the other half half of
that will be people embracing the AI
world so much that they want to marry
the AI and they will have people
literally fighting to be married
to of course that of course that will
happen all the bad things will happen
yes but this is but good things will
also I want to catastrophize
J this is the Divergence you mentioned
because uh so we just bought we're
building we're building freedan and it's
been in construction for a minute but uh
awesome news I mean the drywall is going
up in the in the in the lower Studios uh
yeah we've got the design for the indoor
and out outdoor skate park portion so it
is moving and we're thinking maybe by
February you know it could even be
sooner than that but uh uh we just
bought a sound system from an antique
store from the 9s with cassette vinyl
amfm radio and a CD player and the rule
is when you're playing music in the park
it has to be a vinyl played from start
to finish you will turn the vinyl on you
will go and you'll flip it over you
finish that album before you can play
anything else why I cannot stand the
digital playlist reality I can't stand
that whenever you open the app it's one
song from one band and it's 700 bands
with one song and so I said no no no I
don't want that anymore I want the core
original give me an album from one band
we're listening imagine imagine that
there are adults alive today who have
never listened to the bside of ABY
Road they don't know that that's a thing
yeah yeah they may have heard every song
off of it but that is not the experience
of listening youd be shocked when I
travel with my records how many people
are like what the hell are these they
look them like they're like these
foreign like they pull it out of they
literally see them open the box and then
take it out and they're like looking
like I've never seen this in my life I'm
like dude it's a record like you don't
know what that is really yeah but you be
you'd be amazed people literally have
never seen it before I want to expand
out on what Jeremy was saying too I
agree I love the mixtape but I I this
would be nice if if the positivity does
grow out of this and and uh people
Embrace family again you know that would
be an amazing uh transition out of this
hellscape that we've been in it's
possible because I I'm in a community
now where I'm surrounded by people who
are beautiful families and when I was in
New York I was not surrounded by that at
all it was uh completely defunct and
anti- family I I I do just have to
mention this that we pulled up an
article previously that you were on
Patrick B David's podcast in Miami and
now you're here in effectively West
Virginia and I'm like man
yeah this guy works you were just in
Where Were You you were in uh Bud where
you I've been overseas this is my first
time in the States since July 10th wow
and I scouted for a month in Europe
before that so by Christmas it will be
true that I spent the majority of
2023 overseas wow other than family is
there stuff that you realize you were
missing Mexican
food true that's a big one I missed that
here we don't have Taco Bell yeah we
don't we don't have great Mexican food
in Nashville either but we have some
mexic whenever I go to Texas I'm always
like we need tacos yes time for tacos
but to be fair the American versions of
it are nowhere near what Mexican food
actually is oh yeah but it's ours you
know know I like the American versions
when I say Mexican food I mean TexMex
yeah I want I want like the American
version of Chinese food I want SE
cucumbers I want like General s chicken
and some you know low M thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net